my name is Edie Boyden I'm an associate
professor here at the MIT Media Lab in
McGovern Institute in the department's
of brain and cogs I and biological
engineering here at MIT for hundreds of
years
mike escapists have been trying to look
at biology typically you take a glass
lens and magnify the light coming from a
sample and you get an image that's
bigger and so you can see it but there's
a problem all of these existing
microscopy methods are limited they
can't take a 3-dimensional image of a
large sample with nanoscale precision
and so we thought well what if we did
something different in the last three
hundred years rather than using glass
lenses to magnify the rays of light
let's just blow up the actual sample and
make it bigger so the way that this idea
came about is that we actually spent
several months just brainstorming about
it in a very daydreaming kind of way Oh
wouldn't it be great if we could just
expand the tissue you could see so much
more detail by doing that and wouldn't
it be awesome we kind of drew out a lot
of ideas and rejected a lot of ideas
until finally something stuck we
discovered that by embedding a piece of
tissue in a swellable material you can
physically expand that tissue so we
looked through the literature and we
just found the most well characterized
swellable polymer there is which turns
out to be the thing that is used in baby
diapers so when baby diapers is our
water
there's polymers in here that will swell
up to become very very large that's how
they absorb so much water expansion
microscopy is not a new microscope is a
series of steps which we apply to the
sample to physically magnify it first
you label the structure you want to see
with a fluorescent dye that will be
anchored into the network second you
deliver the precursor and then you form
the chemical Network right there inside
the specimen next you have to chop up
all the endogenous structure in the
tissue so that it will not resist
expansion and then finally you put it
into pure salt free water and it
spontaneously expands with this
technology the polymer network
extends four to five times in all three
dimensions evenly so the relative shape
of the structures you want to look at
stays the same it's just bigger this is
important because this means anyone out
in the world can apply those steps to
their sample and put it on the
microscopes that they already own to
make their microscopes into super
resolution microscope with expansion
microscopy we can image whole 3d volumes
at a resolution of tens of nanometers
what's cool about this is that you
actually can start to try to navigate
brain circuits you can scan large chunks
of brain tissue but with nanoscale
precision and so we think that this
technology can help a lot of different
questions be answered in biology and in
medicine